Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Du, völlig überraschend gehen die Zahlen total durch die Decke. Wir müssen irgendwas unternehmen sofort.
Wir können in vierzehn Tagen ja die Notbremse ziehen.
Lokbuch, Netzpolitik Nummer dreihundertneunundachtzig, dreihundertneunundachtzig, genau vom was haben wir? Vierzehnten April zwanzig einundzwanzig. Eure Spaßbremse in Zeiten der Not.
Äh ist gesetzt.
Nur hier die echten geilen, schlechten Nachrichten,
so wie es gewohnt seid. Wenn wir jetzt mal anfangen würden, zehn gute Nachrichten hintereinander zu erzählen, dann würdet ihr euch irgendwie, dann würdet ihr euch doch wundern, ob ihr ob sich jemand in euer Internet reingehackt hat,
Und was jetzt irgendwie wieder passiert ist.
Oh Tim.
Ich komm mit diesen mit diesen diese die Not ist ja gar nicht so schlimm. Schlimm ist was wir daraus machen.
Beziehungsweise nicht machen.
Ja. Oh weh, oh weh, lasst es uns verschlimmern.
Brücken, Brückenaligurien. Es ist einfach man hat wirklich das Gefühl, es sind einfach alle völlig am Ende ihrer intellektuellen Leistungsfähigkeit äh angekommen.
Als wir es als ob einfach sich nicht mehr produzieren lässt, so wie setzt da auf die Pumpen und pumpen und es kommt einfach nichts mehr raus.
Man könnte sagen, so der Loktown wirkt langsam. Die Leute sitzt halt wahrscheinlich zu Hause, denken sich so da steht was an der Wand.
Brücken. Doch doch, steht da. Hat der, hat der Teufel an die Wand geschrieben, sage ich jetzt. Also es ist, es ist in einem Ford. Na ja, wir bleiben, wir bleiben auch immer.
Ja, wir versuchen uns äh weiter zu entspannen und ähm das Lustige im Schlimmen zu sehen.
Ja. Und es ist ja eigentlich auch sehr lustig. Es.
Und wir müssen sogar wenn ich das richtig sehe, wieder viel über das Red, wo wir uns seit Wochen drüber reden, obwohl wir eigentlich überhaupt gar keine Lust haben, dadrüber zu reden.
Ja. Das ist ja, das komme ich irgendwie. Lass uns erstmal noch kurz das Feedback besprechen.
Also zur LMP drei acht sieben haben wir eine Mail bekommen von Cybercow, Cybercow sagt
in LMP drei acht sieben habt ihr die Geschehnisse um die Corona Warnap so hingestellt als hätte die Regierung davon Anfang an eine gute Strategie verfolgt und keiner wisse warum. Ich habe das jedoch anders in Erinnerung,
und kann das nicht einfach so stehen lassen. Meines Wissens war zu Beginn ein zentraler Ansatz geplant. Und auch von Veröffentlichung des Source Codes war so wie ich es im Kopf habe zu Beginn keine Rede. Erst als Zahlen.
Einflussreich genug Menschen dafür trommelten, eine ordentliche Implementierung zu verlangen.
Anderenfalls von der Nutzung abzuraten kam kurz darauf die Ankündigung, man wolle den Sourcode veröffentlichen und von einer zentralen Speicherrose mal ab, aber vermutlich wisst ihr das genauer. Ich fände es nur schade, die Lorbeeren
irgendein wie auch immer gearteten Zufall zuzuschreiben.
Wenn sich doch in Wirklichkeit eine aufmerksame Zivilgesellschaft darum verdient gemacht hat, liebe Grüße Cyberchao, danke Cybercow hast du recht. Ähm ich finde nur Eigenlob stinkt, deswegen äh haben wir hier mal die Lorbeeren,
der Bundesregierung gegeben, es ist richtig, es gab damals eine Debatte die auch heiß geführt wurde, auch um Ostern übrigens und ähm.
Es war dann äh der der damals oder der anfängt, die anfänglich, ähm wie nennt man das akademische Debatte zwischen,
PT hieß das, glaube ich, ne. Und,
P drei T, wo ich immer mit den Akonym, mit dem werde ich mich, werde ich nicht mehr klarkommen
die dann eben darin mündete, damals übrigens auch der CCC mit den zehn Prüfsteinen für Contact Racing Apps, glaube ich, einen wichtigen Beitrag geleistet und ähm.
Mündete dann in der Entscheidung der Bundesregierung äh dieses Mal sich unter unter dem unter dem massiven Druck sich dann doch der Ratio zu beugen. Und äh da hast du, hast du Recht, man, aber,
Man muss jetzt natürlich auch sagen, äh Druck der Zivilgesellschaft hin und her, letztendlich ist es etwas, was Google und Apple entschieden haben. Ja ähm was und zwar damit einfach durch die,
normative Kraft des des Fraveworks gesagt haben, was bei uns in den Shop kommt und was bei uns in den App Store kommt und was nicht.
Das kann man schon mal so stehen lassen. Also ich war ein bisschen überrascht über seine Formulierung, dass wir das so dargestellt hätten, weil wir uns ja eigentlich.
Die ganze Zeit mit dem Thema hier beschäftigt haben und äh vielleicht kam es aus einer Sendung anders heraus, aber ich denke so insgesamt ist auch klar geworden
Dass wir am Anfang da viel Kritik geäußert haben, es dann halt heftig wurde und am Ende ja eigentlich einen ganz guten Weg genommen hat. Das sieht man jetzt insbesondere, wenn man sich so anschaut, wohin andere so abbiegen.
Richtig und also das ist ja auch der das der Grund oder der der,
Dafür führt man ja eben auch politische Debatten und bringt sich ein und das ist auch so ein bisschen der der Grund, warum ich finde,
Ist jetzt so ein persönliches Ding, dass man dann auch nicht großartig nachtragend sein muss, ne? Also eine richtige Entscheidung ist immer noch richtig, auch wenn sie ähm,
wenn man ursprünglich was anderes gemacht hat und da äh das ist jetzt wirklich einfach so eine Frage von von,
Diskussionsstil, dass ich da jetzt ähm eben auch anerkenne, dass sie eine richtige Entscheidung getroffen haben,
nicht unbedingt betonen möchte, dass sie die dass sie ursprünglich eine andere treffen sollten. Da sollte man jetzt vielleicht auch gar nicht so so hemisch oder nachtragend sein, weil ähm das kann man ja also eine richtige Entscheidung gehört gelobt, äh egal,
welcher Form.
Andersrum wäre es schlimm.
Auch wenn man sie quasi erzwungen hat. Ähm,
Dann haben wir von Micha noch Feedback, das habe ich auch erwartet, dass das Feedback wieder kommt, wenn wir unseren Fachbereich äh verlassen, dann äh gehen wir in den Bereich der Ungenauigkeiten.
Micha hat kommentiert. Erst einmal, ich mag eure Sendung sehr. Dann aber noch eine Richtigstellung MSA sind mitnichten harmlos. Es gibt jährlich,
zehntausend bis zwanzigtausend Todesfälle in Deutschland, MRSA, also diese Antibiotikaresistenten, Keime.
Multiresistenten.
Genau, wo ich gesagt habe, ähm dass die äh Verhältnismäßig ähm.
Also dass die nicht der größte anzunehmende Unglücksfall sind und trotzdem ist es korrekt, dass äh vier zu vielen Todesfällen.
Ähm weil es eben ja die die Heilung äh letztendlich ähm hindert und äh führt häufig zum Tod nicht nur in,
äh in irgendwelchen Sonderfällen, die durch die Krankheit und Tod verloren gegangene Lebensjahre liegen in Deutschland bei knapp zweihundertfünfzigtausend,
pro Jahr.
Nicht wenig.
Drei, das sind dreihundertundneun verlorene Lebensjahre pro hunderttausend Einwohner
Der Anteil der Patienten, die während eines Krankenhausaufenthalt, eine äh Infektion bekommen ist in Deutschland mit rund drei Komma sechs Prozent niedriger als im U Durchschnitt, aber ich meine
drei Komma sechs Prozent ist eine schlechte Wette, ne? Das also ist ein ist ein großes Problem und ich wollte auch nicht den Eindruck erwecken, dass es nicht so sei.
Trotzdem ist es nur ein Vorgeschmack darauf, was los ist, wenn mal richtig aggressive Keime äh diesen diesen Status erlangen, da da können wir noch mit ganz anderen,
ähm raten, rechnen.
Ja, aber danke, danke Micha zu diesem Punkt.
Jo und damit wären wir beim ersten Thema. Und das zum Thema Tim, da wollten wir eigentlich nie drüber sprechen, ne?
Ja nee, zumindest nicht drei Sendungen hintereinander. Das hätte jetzt nicht unbedingt sein müssen.
Wir haben eigentlich gesagt, wir machen die Luca-Sendung zu äh to and all Luca Discussions mit Eva Wolfangel, haben wir gemacht, hat auch hat auch eigentlich gereicht, wurde jetzt auch hier vom.
Von den Mainstream-Medien äh anerkannt.
Oh Gott.
MSM Tim heißt das, ne? Man sagt MSM. Ja.
MSM, A, Mainstream Medien.
Ja, typisches MSM. Kennen wir alles schon.
Aha. Wo Bümmerman.
Genau, bin beim eher klar, typischer äh GEZ MSM gibt's alles eine so.
Ja
Genau, aber jedenfalls, äh, der, der hat das auch, hat auch darauf verwiesen auf diese Sendung,
haben wir jetzt in in den Downloadzahlen nicht mehr gemerkt, aber das sind natürlich auch einfach kleine kleinere Peaks, die waschen sich heraus. Und ähm.
Zum Mainstream sind die nämlich gar nicht die Medien.
Wahre Mainstream ist hier.
Genau, der wahre Mainstream ist hier ähm,
Genau, wir wollten eigentlich die Luca-Sendung Luca Discussions machen. Ähm, hat nicht gereicht, weil es werden ja es es kommen ja jeden Tag neue Schwachstellen raus bei Luca und so ähm erfuhr ich dann.
Kürzlich von der Schwachstelle Luca Track. Ähm habe da ein bisschen,
vorher Einblick bekommen als es als die Veröffentlichung stattgefunden hat und hab mir dann gedacht OK jetzt reicht's,
ja wir haben ja eigentlich als CCC gesagt, wir wir ignorieren das und geben denen nicht noch mehr. Aufmerksamkeit aber ähm.
Das musste jetzt dann mal reichen, um den
um eine Bundesnotbremse für Luca zu fordern. Das haben wir dann gestern Abend gemacht und haben einen etwas längeren Beitrag dazu geschrieben, ne, dass es eben ein zweifelhaftes Geschäftsmodell ist, die Software mangelhaft ist. Und.
Durchaus eben Unregelmäßigkeiten bei der Auftragsvergabe gibt. Das haben wir hier.
Alles auch schon im Logbuch behandelt. Ähm was wir noch nicht behandelt haben, ist diese Luca Track Schwachstelle und die geht ungefähr so. Ähm.
Die haben ja gesagt für Leute, die keine Handys haben, die sie mit der Luca-App äh weilen können,
soll es dann eben Schlüsselanhänger geben. Das ist ja immer eines der Argumente bei den digitalen Lösungen, sei es Koravan, App, sei es irgendwelche Check-in-Apps, haste nicht gesehen. Ja, aber was ist mit den Leuten ohne Smartphone.
Und dann haben sie gesagt, alles klar, gar kein ist gar kein Problem. Da drucken wir euch einen QR-Code auf einen Schlüsselanhänger und dann könnt ihr die Schlüsselanhänger bei uns kaufen zum Stück
Preis von, ich glaub irgendwie dreißig Cent oder so was. Und dann könnt ihr die den Leuten geben und dann können die sich damit einchecken.
Und jetzt haben sie aber natürlich auch das wieder mit der heißen Nadel gestrickt und erst äh released und dann drüber nachgedacht und dieser Schlüsselanhänger ist ja quasi,
statisch, ne? Es sind statischer äh Schlüsselanhänger. Der QR-Code, den kannst du ja nicht ändern. Und in dem QR-Code findest du
Wenn du dir den, wenn du jetzt den QR-Code hast, findest du das den Tracing Seat. Du findest eine User-ID da drin äh und,
den Tracing Seed und aus dem Tracing Seat wird eine äh aus dem Tracing Seat und der Zeit ähm,
wird quasi eine Trace ID. Und damit imitiert das Ding,
quasi den QR-Code einer App nur, wenn du äh wenn du es mit der App machst, ist dieser eben nicht notwendigerweise statisch, denn der ändert sich ja alle Minute. Bei einem äh bei diesem ausgedruckten QR-Code ist der statisch. Und deswegen
langer Rede kurzer Sinn ist in dem ähm,
Wenn du den QR-Code scannst, ist da das Geheimnis drin, was du brauchst, um alle anderen Check-Ins dir von deren API abzuholen,
Weil du weißt, welcher Code da am Ende bei rausgekommen wäre, wenn du dort eincheckst. Und da haben dann eben.
Tobias Ravenstein und Bianca Kastel ähm sich mal mit auseinandergesetzt und haben einen Srips geschrieben, was genau das macht. Du scannst einen QR-Code,
und dann geht der durch und sucht dir die Check-Ins raus, wo du warst und kann dir die ganze Dackel auch direkt fertiggebaut. Das war mein kleiner Vorschlag. Das ist dann direkt auf so einer äh auf so einer Map dargestellt wird
ne? Dann siehst du quasi die äh siehst du nicht nur die Liste, wo die Leute waren, sondern hast direkt noch so eine kleine grafische Darstellung auf einer auf einer Weltkarte oder auf einer Deutschlandkarte
Ähm mit anderen Worten, wenn du jetzt bei jemandem auftrittst, ja und sagst, hier ist mein äh Schlüsselanhänger
Scann mich mal, dann kann die Person erstens dich in Zukunft überall sonst auch einscannen. Das ist diese ganze äh Böhmermann-Geschichte, ne, hier zu nachts im Zoo von Osnabrück und so. Und sie kann aber auch quasi sehen, wo du schon wann warst.
Und,
natürlich völlig unnötig, ne, warum hast du das Geheimnis fix in dem Code drin? Das ist alles äh halt ja keine keine sinnvolle,
Bereicherung. Das ist einfach nur wieder handwerklicher Quatsch, den sie da gebaut haben. Der fliegt ja dann eben um die Ohren und da musst du dich nicht wundern, dann kriegst du halt Post,
dann darfst du Schwachstellen fixen.
Ja, könnt ihr euch auch alle anschauen unter Luca Treck Punkt DE.
Genau. Und wir haben dann eben als CC gesagt, okay, jetzt reicht's. Ähm ne, diese Kowitt-Glücksritter, das muss jetzt mal langsam aufhören. Und.
Wir haben ja in der, wie gesagt, in der letzten Sendung noch darüber spekuliert, wie viel Geld da reingeflossen ist. Es sind aber inzwischen über zwanzig Millionen Euro.
Und diese ähm das habe ich auch in der letzten Sendung nur im im vor im kleinen Rahmen behandelt, dass die natürlich,
schon längst Pläne haben für eine Monetarisierung dieses Systems, wenn es einmal nicht mehr benötigt wird.
Also zumindest bin's nicht für Corona mehr benötigt wird.
Genau und jetzt haben wir natürlich, jetzt haben wir eine Situation in der Mecklenburg-Vorpommern quasi die Verwendung dieser App ja mehr oder weniger verpflichtend macht per Verordnung
Ähm die starten, die Bundesländer, da die ganze Kohle reingeschoben haben für eine Einjahreslizenz. Und in diesem einen Jahr,
baut Nixenio, jetzt in Ruhe diese App aus, ne? Macht die zum Defakto-Standort, äh zum zum Defakto-Standard und dann ist die Pandemie entweder vorbei,
gut, ähm dann würden eben dann ja,
versiegt der äh Steuergeldregen und die müssen gucken, wie sie den Laden weiter am am Kacken halten. Und da ist es natürlich total günstig, wenn man schon mal überlegt hat, ähm dass man das anbindet an.
Ticketingsysteme
und in den Luka Präsentationen, ich hatte ja aus einer schon zitiert, wo sie da ganz klar drüber sinieren, äh in anderen, die man bei frag den Staat findet, steht dann schon groß drin, so Anbindung an eine breite
an breite Geschäftsmodelle möglich, ja? Also da sinieren sie schon sehr klar von und wenn man sich die die
Die Markenanmeldung für den Namen Luca anschaut, da findet man dann für welche Bereiche,
die das alles schon mal die Marke angemeldet haben, ne? Reservierung von Tickets für Veranstaltung, insbesondere für Kultur und Sportveranstaltung, politische Veranstaltung, Veranstaltungen für Bildungs und Fortbildungszwecke und für wissenschaftliche Tagungen, Ausstellen von Tickets für Veranstaltungen in elektronischer oder physisch manifester Form
Eintrittskarten, Vorverkauf. Ähm, ja und das macht aus wirtschaftlicher,
Perspektive durchaus Sinn in der CC PM haben wir das mal unternehmerische Weitsicht genannt.
Ja, haben wir draufgehauen. Luca Track wurde den gestern Abend gemeldet, haben sie relativ zügig abgestellt oder zumindest,
bekannt gegeben, sie hätten es abgestellt, es ist ja immer so, wenn du jetzt eine Schwachstelle demonstriert hast und jemand sagt, ich habe die jetzt abgestellt, musst du halt schauen, wo die jetzt wirklich das Problem an der Wurzel behoben,
oder funktioniert nur deine Demonstration gerade nicht mehr, ne? Und ähm dass deswegen können wir und hat auch Luca Track und niemand anders eine,
Aussage dazu getroffen.
Ob das jetzt äh behoben ist oder nicht. So, da zitiert man dann eben die Betreiber und das ist äh auch richtig und notwendig so. Jetzt wollen wir aber, das ist ja nicht alles, ne? Also diese diese,
Schlüsselanhänger sind das eine Problem. Ja, dann haben wir aber schon darüber gesprochen,
dass ihr diese SMS nicht validieren. In der Recherche von Chris Köver bei Netzbeuth Org zu den Kosten stellt sich raus, dass fast fünfzig Prozent der Kosten für diesen SMS-Versand draufgehen,
Ja, aber dieser SMS-Versand ist völlig unnötig, weil er umgehbar ist. Das heißt, wir geben jetzt Millionen an Steuergeldern aus, um irgendwelche SMS zu versenden,
die ähm die ihren Validierungszweck nicht erfüllen. So, geht aber noch weiter. Eine andere Leute haben gezeigt.
Das haben wir glaube ich auch schon besprochen, dass du diese SMS beliebig triggern kannst,
Das heißt, wenn du jetzt irgendwie eine Arm machen willst oder den schneller das Steuergeld aus der Tasche zurückziehen möchtest in den Kreislauf ähm
dann triggerst du jetzt einfach die ganze Zeit SMS an alle möglichen Random Nummern, weil sie halt keine ähm ähm keine kein Capture davor haben, ne? Wäre ich aber vorsichtig mit, weil wahrscheinlich steht in den Verträgen, dass die Rechnung nachher an Vaterstaat geht. Ähm
Also mit dem Geld gehen sie da auf jeden Fall großzügig um. Und das hat aber auch wieder zur Folge, weil sie die SMS nicht.
Ähm nicht korrekt äh erfassen und die Telefonnummer nicht korrekt validieren, dass du Random,
gültige Luca QR-Codes bauen kannst. Und wenn du Random gültige QR-Codes bauen kannst, dann kannst du dich eben auch mit denen.
Codes, also es sind ja nicht nur QR-Codes, sondern eben äh Nutzer-IDs, mit denen kannst du dich auch automatisiert überall einloggen. So,
Das klingt jetzt noch ein bisschen abstrakt, aber das heißt eigentlich, du nimmst die Adresse von irgendjemandem, den du nicht magst,
generierst Luca Check in QR-Codes dafür oder Luca Checkin Codes dafür und kannst ohne die zu scannen.
Ähm dich dann quasi über die API, über die Webseite bei Luca, kannst du deinen Nachbarn dann überall einchecken,
Wenn du das jetzt skalierst, dann hast du halt, sagen wir mal, würfelst du einfach hunderttausende Menschen.
Und checkst die überall ein, machst sorgst dafür, dass jede politische Veranstaltung oder was auch immer, die mit Luca getrackt wird. Ähm,
von hunderttausend Fake-Menschen besucht wird. Und die haben momentan keine wirksame Verteidigung dagegen
Und das ist ein, das ist der Grund, warum du nicht so einen zentralen Ansatz ähm haben möchtest. Außerdem, das äh will ich hier auch erwähnen, hat jemand mit Namen, Moment, wo habe ich's
äh weigernd Lebs auf Twitter, hat direkt einfach mal eine komplette
Luca Appoberfläche gemacht, die einfachen gültigen Random Co-R-Court macht. Und den Court das Ding öffentlich gemacht. Das heißt, du kannst jetzt einfach mit so einer,
Du machst eigentlich ein Browserfenster auf,
ja? Das würfelt dir einen Random gültigen QR-Code für Luca und damit kannst du gültig einchecken an jeder Location.
Das heißt, in diesem QR-Gold ist auch keinerlei äh Autorisierung der App oder so, dass man sicherstellen könnte.
Das ist jetzt also das das ist natürlich also das ist.
Man könnte auch sagen, das ist ein Sicherheitsfeature, weil die Daten ja verschlüsselt sind. Das heißt, die können überhaupt nicht validieren, dass du denen valide Daten gibst.
Weil sie eben die Telefonnummer nicht validieren, können sie auch nicht sicherstellen, dass sie überhaupt einen validen Account hast. Und dadurch kannst du eben denen einfach irgendeinen QR-Code zeigen
und dann wird halt irgendwelcher Müll bei denen in die Datenbank geschrieben, aber wie gesagt, das ist jetzt, sage ich mal so, das Datenschützers äh unter das, das ähm
Privacy Affinen Nutzers Donald Duck, ne? Ähm mit Random Daten das System zu füttern ist,
ja also es wäre eine Umgehung von einem Luca Appzwang, ne? Aber wie gesagt, das ist natürlich auch der Schnitt ins eigene Fleisch. Im Zweifelsfall nicht ähm.
Alarmiert zu werden.
Ähm aber das Ding zu Ende gedacht ist halt, du du checkst einfach tausende von nicht existierenden Menschen an allen Orten dieser Welt ein äh oder dieses Landes ein,
Oder der Bundesländer, die den Mist gekauft haben, ein und machst das ganze System,
nutzlos, ne? Und das sind eben so Dinge, über die muss man sich eben mal Gedanken machen. Schmudo to go heißt dieses Fake-Code-System. Ähm,
Herzlichen Glückwunsch zu dieser Schwachstelle und die ist nach meinem Befinden also die Luca Macher, den wurde die schon vor Wochen mitgeteilt, die ähm ignorieren die.
Kann man nur hoffen, dass niemand wirklich mal den die den Exploid zu Ende bastelt und auch zur Anwendung bringt, weil dann könne das Ding ein einklappen, ne? Dann ist das vorbei. Und sowas kommt von sowas.
Ja, ich äh muss halt immer überlegen, so okay, was sind jetzt Technologiedemonstrationen und was sind äh auch reale Angriffe, ne? Also
es muss ja auch immer eine gewisse Motivation geben, dass das sowas auch wirklich zum Einsatz gebracht wird, beziehungsweise was sind Angriffsszenarien
wo man dann wirklich gezielt bestimmten Leuten schaden kann. Und das ist hier glaube ich so ein bisschen dazwischen, ne?
Du könntest dieses System einfach kaputt machen, ne? Ähm indem du.
Indem du einfach an jeden Ort alle möglichen Leute eincheckst und jedes egal von welchem Ort das Gesundheitsamt äh Daten haben will, waren hunderttausend Leute da.
Und dann können sie mal gucken, wer wirklich da war. Da müsst ihr, da, wer dann, ne, das da das ist halt in einem dezentralen System quasi egal,
weil es die Leute wenigstens gibt und die ja wissen, die Notification ist Unsinn, die haben sich ja selber absichtlich dort eingecheckt. Aber in diesem umgedrehten Fall die Location checkt dich,
hast du halt also hast du diese Spam-Möglichkeit? Es ist halt leider so, kriegst du auch nicht weg.
Na ja, also das, das ist jetzt so das eine Ding. Ähm dann äh genau die Schlüsselanhänger sind kaputt.
Dann hat noch jemand sich mal angeschaut äh die Luca App wirbt ja mit dem,
automatischen automatischen Checkout. Der hat aber zur Folge, dass sie, dass dass die App quasi die ganze Zeit mit diesem Backend redet. Ja, also die haben tatsächlich die ganze Zeit, die wissen von jeder einzelnen,
App, dass sie eingecheckt ist und sie können auch die ähm diese App Installation
über IP-Adressen und Reboot des Gerätes und so weiter. Ähm ein eindeutig identifizieren. Also könnten, ne? Es wird etwas mitgesendet, was ausreicht, um das zu tun. Und damit ist diese gesamte ähm,
Verschlüsselung und Unverkettbarkeit nicht mehr gegeben. Also die Verschlüsselung ist noch gegeben, aber du hast eben die, du hast, es ist nicht so, dass es eine wirklich anonyme Nutzung ist, wenn du das mit der App tatsächlich machst.
Warum ist in die App noch verbunden.
Die Vermutung ist, dass sie das für diesen Auto-Checkout machen, weil die App quasi der Autocheckot wird darüber gelöst, dass die App quasi so eine Art Keep i Life sendet.
Ich verstehe auch nicht, warum die das so gemacht haben, aber ich verstehe bei vielen, äh, was die gemacht haben, nicht so. Äh nicht wirklich, was das soll,
und äh da verlinke ich jetzt hier auf ähm,
einen äh von Marme zweiundachtzig auf Gitter äh zusammengefasste Forschung, wo eben er quasi in dem Traffic guckt, dass seine ähm,
seine Luka App da die ganze Zeit hingepostet hat in drei Sekunden Intervall und so. Also es ist auch wieder es ist.
Schade.
Könnt ihr das auch erklären warum bei äh Null Linzes äh Demonstrationen mit seiner Privatparty wurde wurden ja diese Ladezeiten noch irgendwie immer länger, umso mehr Leute sich da eingecheckt haben.
Genau das liegt aber wahrscheinlich, also den Teil habe ich mir noch nicht genau angeschaut, aber da lieg.
Vermutlich daran, dass du irgendeine Entschlüsselung oder Kryptooperation auf jeden einzelnen Nutzer machst.
Die da nicht entsprechend skaliert, wenn's viele sind.
Richtig. Ja, aber das habe ich mir nicht im Detail angeschaut. Deswegen.
Okay.
Na ja, aber das sind halt alles so so Dinge, über die man halt schon mal vorher ein bisschen nachdenken äh muss in seinem Softwaredesign, wie eskaliert das und so weiter. Na ja. Aber das war's ja jetzt auch noch nicht, ne? Die Liste geht dann noch immer noch weiter.
Eine. Ja, ja, die, die Liste geht weiter. Ähm Moment, ich habe dir jetzt schon wieder zugehabt, aber das war, das wäre jetzt so die die eklatanten Handwerklichen Fehler, die eben auch viele der Sicherheitsversprechen,
ähm in Frage stellen, äh wir hatten über diese Lizenzgeschichte gesprochen. Wir haben auch darüber gesprochen, dass äh das Ding nicht barrierefrei ist, was natürlich auch bei einer verordneten Nutzung problematisch ist. Und wir haben auch darüber gesprochen, dass
noch nicht alles äh,
veröffentlicht wurde an Quellcode. Und da die lieben Lukas äh heute ein bisschen im Kreuzfeuer standen in der medialen Aufmerksamkeit. Haben sie gesagt, was können wir denn jetzt mal für eine gute Nachricht machen? Veröffentlichen wir einfach mal den Serverquellcode.
Ja? Und wir waren wir als wir hier gerade mit der Sendung begannen, twitterte Andreas Book ein Private Key, der,
Und das ist, muss ich jetzt sagen, weil wir's jetzt gerade gesehen haben,
der sieht danach aus, dass es halt der SSL Private Key ist oder ein SSL Private Key ähm wir haben aber noch nicht gesehen.
Oder bis jetzt noch nicht ähm verifiziert, dass das auch der aus dem Produktivsystem ist. Es wäre denkbar, dass das nicht der ähm,
der Produktivkey ist, sondern vielleicht aus irgendeinem Test oder Staging System.
Gibt aber trotzdem keinen Grund, solche Kies äh überhaupt mit äh einzuchecken, wenn man so ein Public Release macht.
Wenn in deinem Commit drinsteht, beginne Private Key, dann musst du dir den Commit nochmal angucken.
Ja? Und das ist auch nicht alles, weil wenn da außerdem noch drinsteht Postgress DB, Luca Minus Backend, Postgress User Luca, Poscret Passwort LC Admin, da musst du auch nochmal deinen Comic angucken.
Und wenn da außerdem noch so was drin steht wie.
New E To E Welle Passwort gleich Nexenio eins zwei drei Ausrufezeichen.
Dann musst du auch nochmal deinen Comic angucken und irgendwie deine Passwortrichtlinie. Weil Firmen haben wir eins, zwei, drei Ausrufezeichen, ähm wird teilweise von ab abgeraten.
Okay, du sagst, wenn das so ist, ist es denn so?
So ist es ja. Äh ich sehe gerade Andreas hat getwittert, es ist nicht der äh Private Keep zu einem vertrauten,
Zertifikat. Also es ist äh was ich schon äh vermutet habe, nicht jetzt unbedingt, dass das Prott äh Zertifikat ähm.
Aber ähm es ist ein äh also es ist nicht das, was jetzt irgendwie für Luca Minus App DE ist, ähm aber
es ist immerhin ein Iros A Private Key und ja das reizt sich halt einfach nur ein, ja? Das reizt sich einfach nur ein
dass jemand, der irgendwie, wenn wenn Schiffe reinkommt und sagt, ey Scheiße, Gönner, äh wir haben schon wieder eine Schwachstelle und die machen uns hier Druck, machen mal den Servercode öffentlich und dann sagt halt einer, ne, Git Ad Stern.
Geht come mit, geht push und dann hast du halt deine Kies da äh online. Und deine Passwörter.
Ja, also wir wissen nicht genau, was die Kies machen, aber wir wir wissen, was die Kies äh nicht machen, sie erhöhen nicht das Vertrauen in dieses Projekt.
Nee. Nein, das, also diesem Projekt sollte man auch nicht vertrauen. Das haben wir ja auch gesagt. Also es dieses Projekt lebt davon.
Dass es von Smodo beworben wird, seit drei Monaten sehr offensiv und,
auch erst die haben ja irgendwie erst im November oder so angefangen das zu basteln wo es schon sehr viele Konkurrentinnen gab auf dem Markt. Wir haben das ja hier auch erwähnt, damit wir wir für Digitalisierung, das sind über dreißig Mitbewerberinnen,
die das nicht äh die sich dagegen wenden und die aber vor allem.
CoWET-Apps gebaut haben und nicht irgendwelche Ticketingsystemapps, die schon heute vom Geschäftsmodell von morgen.
Träumen. Und da denke ich, sollte man tatsächlich sich jetzt mal Gedanken machen. Ähm,
das mal durch die Rechnungshöfe prüfen lassen und von mir aus auch durch einen Untersuchungsausschuss oder sonst was, weil es kann nicht sein, dass in Zeiten der Krise hier Millionen,
Staatsan Lizenzkosten für eine Privatwirtschaftliche App,
rausgegeben werden, die für die Zeit nach der Pandemie oder nach der staatlichen Förderung schon ganz ungeniert von anderen Geschäftsmodellen,
äh äh träumt. Und was ich denke, ne? Ich meine, der der typische Start-up-Gründer, das ist ja kein arbeitsaffiner Mensch, äh sondern gerade solche Dinger, die werden ja schnell aus dem Boden gestampft,
um dann möglichst zügig zu verkaufen, ne? Und da werden natürlich sowas wie.
Hier, wie heißen sie denn? Ticket, hast du nicht gesehen. Wie heißen denn diese großen Eventim oder so, ne? Wenn du denen sagst, hör mal, wir haben hier eine eine Marktdurchdringung von zwanzig Millionen staatlich gefördert.
Kaufen oder nicht, das wäre natürlich der der Exit.
Genau.
Ja, ist schon echt äh schade.
Ja, ist sehr schade und es ist vor allem auch immer noch sehr still, um die potenziellen neuen Features der Corona Warn-App. Die ja ähnliche äh Features ähm ankündigen. Darüber wird irgendwie noch überhaupt nicht gesprochen.
Ja, das, das haben wir auch nochmal in der CCPM mit aufgenommen, weil,
spätestens da müsst ihr jetzt wirklich dann mal die Frage äh des Recht der Rechnungshöfe kommen und sagen so wenn wir einerseits hohe Millionenbeträge,
Von Bundesseite in eine App ins,
investieren, die uns dann gehört, die quelloffen ist, ne, die vom RKI betrieben wird oder die unter Schirmherrschaft des RKI betrieben wird. Warum werfen dann die Länder nochmal äh zwanzig Millionen in eine Konkurrenz,
Ja? Und warum ähm wird werden nicht die Verordnung dahingehend geändert, dass sie die sinnvolle Ergänzung und Erweiterung der oder hoffentlich sinnvolle Ergänzung und Erweiterung der Korona Warnapp legal möglich machen? Warum lässt man.
Hier eine Lücke, die dann von einem privatwirtschaftlichen Unternehmen äh gefüllt wird.
Ja und vor allem wenn es so ist, dass sie aus irgendwelchen Gründen der Meinung sind, dass die Features der Corona Warn-App oder auch nur die geplanten Features dieser Chorona Warnapp nicht ausreichen, um ihre Pläne umzusetzen.
Ja oder das, was sie, was sie meinen, was äh erforderlich ist,
warum diskutieren die dann nicht dadrüber, wo ist die die Taskforce der Bundesländer, die die Interessen äh akkumuliert und dann gezielt mit der Projektgruppe der Corona Warn-App äh diskutiert,
seit Monaten so, ja. Gut, vielleicht gibt's die, aber wenn's die gibt, warum? Warum denn überhaupt noch ein zweites Projekt nebenbei? Wo dann.
Wo dann Ministerpräsidenten für die Kamera treten und sagen, ich verstehe das zwar nichts von. Und ich habe mir auch die Details nicht angeschaut, aber ich habe es einfach mal bestellt.
Also besser kann man auch wirklich seine seine Inkompetenz und auch seine seine seine totale Verantwortungslosigkeit nicht öffentlich dokumentieren.
Ja, also ich habe keine Ahnung, aber äh ich habe mal was irgendwas getan, von dem ich äh was habe ich im Fernsehen gesehen.
Ich mache das einfach nur noch fassungslos und leer.
Hier gibt's noch einen sehr schönen Twitter Fred von Benny H, der sich damit aus mit dem Bericht der Stadt Weimar äh auseinandergesetzt hat. Offenbar war die,
Stadt Weimar hat ein Modellprojekt zur Öffnung.
Gemacht und dabei hat sie äh auch äh sich mal die Luca App angeschaut, ja? Und ähm hier in diesem Twit äh Fred von Benny H zitiere ich jetzt mal so ein bisschen, also er hat sich das äh durchgelesen. Ähm,
wenn du kein Netz hast, kannst du auch nicht einchecken oder auschecken, ne? Also im grade in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern könnte das sagen wir mal, äh alle einigen stellen vielleicht eine Rolle spielen, ne.
Vorstellbar.
Zitat aus diesem Bericht,
äh äh die Checkout-Zeiten könnten für die spätere Verwendung und Gesundheitsamt invalide sein, zum Beispiel zu früh oder zu spät, einen nicht durchgeführter Checkout zum Beispiel vergessen,
Smartphone ausgeschaltet, keine mobilen Daten für zu fehlerhaften Zeiten und gegebenenfalls tagelanger digitataler Anwesenheit im Geschäft. Ähm
dann haben sie in einem Elektrofachmarkt, ja, wo wir ja wissen, da ist ja der im Elektrofachmarkt, sind ja vielleicht Leute, die auch sich mit Elektronik auszahlen. De,
Betreiber gelang es nicht den Scanner funktionstüchtig einzurichten, ja? Sie waren nicht in der Lage einem Elektrofachmarkt dabei zu helfen das Scheißding überhaupt ans Laufen zu kriegen dann.
Ähm äh die.
Die doch so funktionsfähige Wald schon eingesetzte Absorgt für ein paar extra Laufrunden, damit Kundinnen sich überhaupt im nächsten Geschäft einloggen konnten, weil wenn du noch irgendwo drin bist, ja
ne, du hast du du hast sie du kommst quasi zum nächsten Geschäft, bist aber noch in einem drin
Die Folge war das Kundin nicht die Möglichkeit hatten, sich im Nachbargeschäft einzuchecken. Sie mussten in Folge dessen mindestens fünfzig Meter von der letzten Check-In-Adresse weggehen
um automatisch ausgecheckt zu werden, um dann im Nachbargeschäft einkaufen zu können.
Also, in der Shopping-Mall musst du dann sozusagen immer einmal zum anderen Ende der Shopping-Wall laufen, bevor das wieder irgendwie ah okay, ist ja interessantes Rooting.
Diese fünfzig Meter Umweg werden ihnen präsentiert von Amazon, ne? Das ist ähm.
Dann äh der Import in Sormas, wo sie die ganze Zeit mit werben, der ist manuell. Jetzt sagen ja immer.
Anbindung ist das sozusagen.
Genau, sie sagen, er ist voll geil, wir haben hier die Schnittstelle an Sormas, ja, was sich da in was sie ja
momentan versprechen können ist, ein Datenimport in Sommers ist manuell möglich. Das Gesundheitsamt sollte vorab die einzelnen Datentabellen jedes Betreibers manuell bereinigen,
damit in Sommers nur relevante Kontaktdaten erfasst werden, ne? Also Datenmüll, den nur mit irgendeiner CSV-Datei äh selber,
da reinkriegen muss. Das ist die, das ist die tolle Anbindung an die Gesundheitsämter, äh die sich hier äh von Weimar berichtet wir.
Die Anbindung an die Gesundheit, das ist eine, das ist eine Importdatei, CSV-Datei, das ist die Anbindung.
Ja, also die diese äh Kowik-Glücksritter twittern, das wäre alles hier viel, viel geiler und dass wir jetzt nur in Weimar bedauerlicher Einzelfall, ne? Äh aber ja dann äh.
Das ist so als wenn du sagst, wir haben jetzt auch E-Mail, aber du die E-Mails werden dann irgendwo ausgedruckt und noch mit der Post zugeschickt.
Hier dann und dann das ist natürlich auch der Punkt, ne, nach erster Beurteilung durch das Gesundheitsamt waren von sechshundertfünfundfünfzig Angefragten und übermittelten Kontakten im Projektzeitraum null,
in Worten null, Kontakte, relevant.
Also das Gesundheitsamt hat dann auch gesagt so, hm äh das ist nett, aber ähm können wir eigentlich nicht gebrauchen, ja?
Null.
Und dann so und dann jetzt kommt der krasseste Teil, ne? Zwanzig Millionen.
Und das muss man echt nochmal sechshundertfünfundfünfzig Leute wurden von einer Location gemeldet, wo jemand infiziert war.
Ich verstehe das so, also ich ich verstehe, dass das.
Und dann schaut sich das Gesundheitsamt sechshundertfünfundfünfzig Kontaktdaten an, um festzustellen, dass keiner davon irgendwie benachrichtigt werden muss.
Ich ich gehe davon aus, dass es jetzt hier ins, also sie, sie sprechen von angefragten Kontakten im Projektzeitraum, wo ich jetzt sagen würde, da ist die Anzahl der Locations nicht mit drin
Ja, im Zweifelsfall waren es mehrere Locations, auf die sich dann sechshundertfünfundfünfzig Kontakte äh verteilen.
Das können ja potentiell mehrere mehrmals die gleiche Person sein, aber so so verstehe ich das. Wie gesagt, ich Benny H hat das hier gelesen, ich zitiere nur.
Dann ähm zwanzig Millionen Euro in für die verschiedenen Länder, die es machen.
Die Stadt Weimar sagt, auch das Fehlen eines telefonischen Supports, um eine schnelle Lösungsfindung zu generieren, störte im Modellversuch.
Ja, haben kein Ticketingsystem äh konnten sie nicht anrufen, ja.
Modellversuch.
In der in der öffentlichen und direkten Kommunikation werden von Luca Informationen und Funktionen benannt, welche sich durch uns die, welche durch uns nicht bestätigt werden können. Mit anderen Worten, ne, Folls Edvertising.
Und das ist jetzt äh das sagen Leute, die es äh äh die es getestet haben.
So wird zum Beispiel über eine Warnfunktion für den Anwender bei Datenabruf gesprochen. Diese Warnung erfolgte bei Abruf durch die Stadtverwaltung Weimar nicht.
Also das ist so richtig geiles Marketing, da muss man wirklich mal sagen,
Ja, also und genau, vor dem Hintergrund haben wir den eben auch gesagt, ey, das braucht jetzt einfach mal eine Bundesnotbremse, das
das kann man nicht weiter machen, das ist die Vergabe, Praxis ist nicht in Ordnung, die handwerkliche Menge, wohin das Auge reicht, da wo es getestet wird, funktioniert es nicht. Und das ist auch nicht überraschend, wie wir in der letzten Sendung auch schon gesagt haben, die konnten ja gar nicht,
das Ding jetzt mal wirklich äh entwickeln, mal testen, ne, mit der Zeit mitgehen.
Andere ich habe jetzt auch äh nicht gesagt, dass andere unbedingt besser werden. Aber andere haben wenigstens mal Erfahrung, die haben einen Wirkbetrieb gemacht, ja. Die können zeigen, dass es funktioniert und diese Luca-Vögel konnten halt jetzt sagen, hier in Weimar haben wir's ausprobiert und,
es hat nicht überhaupt nicht funktioniert. Ah ja.
Toll, müssen wir kaufen, das ist super. Wer muss die dreißig so genau angeschaut? Kaufen wir.
Gleichzeitig dann hast du äh hier Ralf Rottmann ähm hat dann äh so eine so eine starte äh Statistik aus der Luca App ähm.
Ähm,
API gebaut, wo man quasi sieht, welche Gesundheitsämter gibt es? Haben die ihre Registrierung abgeschlossen? Da gibt's jetzt auch nochmal eine Anzahl Gesundheitsämter. Die haben,
Registrierung noch nicht abgeschlossen. Die meisten von denen haben noch nie Traces übermittelt,
ja? Äh insgesamt gab es aber schon äh eine höhere Anzahl ähm äh Tracing Anfragen und dann kann man immer sehen, welches Gesundheitsamt,
wie viele Traces übermittelt hat. Ich habe die Tabelle jetzt mal verlinkt. Äh Ralf schreibt dazu, interessant.
Gesundheitsämter in der Zuständigkeit zahlreicher Politiker, die die Luca App gelobt haben, führten noch gar keine Traces durch,
Ja, also da sind dann Politiker, die sagen voll geil, das funktioniert hier alles super und laut Reifsanalyse hat da noch keiner jemals gebogen, jemals eine Abfrage gemacht
Was ja übrigens auch insgesamt meine meine Basisthese nur bestätigt, dass das ohnehin wertlose Daten sind.
Der der Zoo von Osnabrück ist ja nur ein sehr gutes Beispiel, dass diese Daten ungeeignet sind. Ähm ein
ein Schufgeschäft ist aber ein ebenso gutes Beispiel und deswegen passiert es ja auch nicht
das Gesundheitsämter irgendwelche äh Gastronomischen Einrichtungen dann alle Leute informieren, die da waren oder im Geschäft oder im Gesundheits oder irgendein Amt oder irgendwo sonst was. Diese Daten sind genau wie es hier auch die Stadt Weimar berichtet, eben
nicht relevant. Was relevant ist, ist eine eine schnelle, smarte äh auch manuelle,
Registrierung von Clustern, ja? Also wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel in in einem Restaurant wäre zu sagen, als gar die Menschen, die da an einem Tisch sitzen. Die sind hier mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit eine,
'ne Infektionsgemeinschaft, aber der eben weiter entfernte Nachbartisch mit so geringer Wahrscheinlichkeit Teil des Infektionsgeschehen, dass es, dass man diesen Schwellenwert nicht zur Basis machen kann,
ne? Das ist ja das, also das ist ja hier die Grunddiskussion, dass immer gesagt wird äh
bei fünfzig Prozent der Infektionen wissen wir nicht wo die herkommen. Kommen aus heiterem Himmel. Irgendwo müssen die herkommen,
ne? Das ist richtig. Die müssen irgendwo herkommen. Und jetzt muss man sich überlegen, was haben wir für Daten, die wir erfassen könnten,
als Operationalisierung von potenziellem Effektionsgeschehen. Und bei der Corona Warnet wird eben gesagt, Abstand und Dauer.
Das ist die Operationalisierung für die Möglichkeit einer Ansteckung. Und da da verbirgt sich ja im Prinzip ein Schwellwert hinter,
ne? Menschen können sich wenige Sekunden nah sein und sich anstecken.
Und Menschen können sich sehr lange nah sein und nicht sich nicht anstecken. Ich habe irgendwie letztens gehört, da fehlt mir gerade die Quelle zu, aber das quasi bei einem Großteil der Ehepaare.
Ähm die die Ehepartnerin oder umgekehrt nicht angesteckt wird,
und die schlafen potenziell in einem Raum und haben viel, sind viele Stunden im gleichen Raum und auch da findet keine, ne, selbst weil so lange,
äh langem Aufenthalt in einem Innenraum gemeinsam über mehrere Stunden oder Tage,
findet, nur in fünfzig Prozent der Fälle eine Infektion statt. Und diese ähm,
Ja, Stochastische Verteilung von das überhaupt Infektion stattfindet. Die limitiert natürlich auch sämtliches Erfassungsinstrument, was du hast. So
Abstandsmessung bei der Corona Warne. So den gemeinsamen Check-In im Osnabrücker Zoo und.
Da denke ich, ist eine, wenn man schon sagt, man möchte etwas anderes haben als ähm,
diese Abstandsmessung, man möchte potentiell Cluster erfassen und ich selber hab's ja gefordert im Oktober,
ähm dann erscheint mir ein dezentrales System, was eben auch das Cluster erfasst und den Leuten erlaubt zu sagen, das ist jetzt unser Cluster,
Wir sind, wir nutzen jetzt Crowd-Notify. Hier ist mein QR-Code bitte einmal scannen. Wir sind jetzt ein Cluster. Und wir bestimmen das von vorne herein. Sinnvoll manuell.
Wir hängen jetzt hier zusammen ab und genau.
Genau. Wir sitzen,
drei Stunden draußen im Biergarten, ist aber sonst keiner da. Da brauche ich nicht am Eingang am Bier Biergarten einzuchecken,
ne? Da checke ich in der Runde ein, in der ich da sitze. Und dann habe ich auch eine eine sinnvolle Entscheidung getroffen. Stattdessen stehen jetzt die Leute vorm Ikea und müssen da das Ding scannen. Das ist,
nicht durch.
Klarhin war es noch zu deinem, zu deiner Aussage manchmal äh steckt man noch nicht mal die Ehefrau an, mit der man die ganze Zeit zusammenhängt
Du beziehst jetzt glaube ich so auf die allgemeinen Erkenntnisse von Saas zwei, es ist schon davon auszugehen, dass wir jetzt mit der neuen Variante, mit dem B eins eins sieben, was jetzt überall ist
da die Spielregeln sich äh ändern in der Hinsicht, ne.
Das ist korrekt, äh was ich was ich illustrieren möchte ist ähm,
und das äh ich weiß, ich kann nur sagen, wen ich da zitiere, das ist äh Viola Priesemann, die er in dem Bereich äh auch eine viel zitierte und sehr kompetente Expertin ist. Ähm,
es ist nicht so, dass man eine in eine Infektions, also es gibt keine Infektionswahrscheinlichkeit von eins,
Und weil es keine Infektionswahrscheinlichkeit von eins gibt,
gibt es auch keine Möglichkeit ähm eine Infektionswahrscheinlichkeit korrekt objektiv zu messen.
Ne? Also du kannst nicht definieren, wenn das und das und das und das passiert, dann ist die Infektionswahrscheinlichkeit eins. Und weil du das nicht, weil du das nicht definieren kannst,
kannst du auch kein perfektes Messinstrument machen. Und das bedeutet, wenn dein Messinstrument hat automatisch Folls Negativs.
Entschuldigung, Folzpositive und diese Quote wird wird einfach nur umso größer, je schlechter du,
Infektionsgeschehen operationalisierst und die beste Operationalisierung, die wir kennen ist.
Kurzer, äh, geringer Abstand lange dauer. Das ist die beste Operationalisierung, die wir haben. Und das ist das, was die Corona Warn-App macht.
Das ist die, das ist die Aussage, die ich treffen wollte. Wie gesagt, wie hoch jetzt die Ansteckungswahrscheinlichkeiten sind, zwischen den Menschen ist äh ist, ist für das Argument
de facto noch irrelevant, solange wir keine Definition finden, wo wir sagen, hier in unter diesen Bedingungen ist die Infektionswahrscheinlichkeit eins,
wird jedes Messinstrument eben auch fehlerbehaftet sein.
Ich, ich wollte nur einen Kommentar vorbeugen.
Finde ich super. Okay, damit hätten wir es, hey, hoffentlich haben wir dieses Thema hinter uns, aber ganz ehrlich, Tim, wir haben es noch nicht hinter uns, weil ich.
Also es gibt schon die Diskussion über die nächsten Schwachstellen, ne? Also das ist ein Gift, das Kieps an Gewing.
So ist das.
So, jetzt haben wir aber auch sehr viel darüber gesprochen, ne, dass ja die Corona Warnapp.
Dem britischen Vorbild folgend und der.
Sich an dem Konzept von Crowd Notifire orientierend eine Check-In-Funktionalität dazu bekommen soll.
Und ähm jetzt ist es tatsächlich so, dass in Großbritannien eben äh spezifisch ähm Venus das genutzt haben und jetzt hat ähm.
Ähm haben Apple und Google ein Update der britischen ähm Corona Warn-App.
Gebremst, weil sie sagen ey, in unseren Bedingungen steht Location-Tracking ist nicht ähm.
Erlaubt für ähm Apps, die das Export Notification Framework nutzen.
Kurzer Zwischenhinweis, damit es nicht falsch verstanden wird. Es ist nicht die britische Corona Warnapp S in, die benutzt denselben Code und äh ja, setzt auf auf derselben Basis auf, sondern sie verwenden das sehr befräm,
das ist sozusagen die britische Variante, aber die ist nicht wie die CWA sie,
tut nur äh also die kommuniziert mit dem selben Framework und macht primär mal äh das Gleiche, aber diese Zusatzfunktion, die ist jetzt anders und noch mit hinzugefügt worden und,
die gerät jetzt sozusagen in Konflik.
Exect lee. Und jetzt wird,
Also jetzt sagt Apple, wenn ihr aber jetzt hier spezifische QR-Codes für Locations baut.
Und das scheint hier der Fall zu sein, wo wo also mein Eindruck ist, dass das der Konfliktfall ist, weil weil sie jetzt spezifisch damit werben,
dass man in eine Venue eincheckt und die Venue dann benannt ist und so. Und,
Das scheint mir der Grund zu sein, warum Apple und Google jetzt sagen, nee,
Das ist Location-Tracking, wenn ihr die QR-Codes spezifisch einer Location zuordnet und ähm damit wer ist das eben äh dass das hier Location-Daten getrackt werden und damit ein Verstoß gegen unsere Bedingungen
Während sie offenbar in einer früheren Version das Feature erlaubt haben.
Ähm weil es da noch nicht so klar war, dass es dass es eben auch irgendwie Venue-Check-In genannt wird. Also es ist ein bisschen komisch. Man fragt sich,
ähm warum sie das, warum ihnen das jetzt erst auffällt und ich kann aber auch verstehen, dass sie das Argument bringen. Ich glaube aber nicht,
oder ich hoffe mal nicht, dass äh dass der deutschen Corona Warnapp auch blüht dieses Schicksal, weil die ja eigentlich mit Apple in im regelmäßigen Austausch stehen.
Ja, ich glaube, die haben das Problem auch verstanden und die planen vor allem nicht und so habe ich das jetzt bei der NHAs äh NHS äh App verstanden. Die haben dann halt schon wieder einen zentralen Speicher. So.
Den sie da quasi dahinter gepflanzt haben, sodass eben dieses ganze Location-Check-In auch,
zentral gespeichert wird und das ist das was Apple und Google jetzt gesagt haben ich weiß nicht ob sie's jetzt schon im ersten Schritt dektiert haben. Oft gehen ihnen ja auch solche Updates dann auch erstmal,
ne
Schauen sie auch erstmal dran vorbei, also nicht absichtlich, sondern was weiß ich aus irgendwelchen Gründen, gibt da halt Personen, Menschen, die das irgendwie überprüfen und dann fällt die das halt auf oder nicht
Und jetzt haben sie da einen Riegel vorgezogen, weil sie meinten so, ja Leute, das ganze Favorit haben wir hier freigeschaufelt für euch. Unter der Prämisse
dass wir garantieren, dass hier keine Locations gesammelt werden. Und deswegen hat eure App
kein Zugriff auf äh Ortsfunktionen. Ihr könnt nicht GPS benutzen, ja? Braucht ihr gar nicht erst nachfragen, kriegt ihr nicht. Dann könnt ihr jetzt nicht hinten rum
über diese QR-Code-Geschichte sagen äh hier da ist jetzt mal eine Location, die ist klar identifiziert, die hat einen Ort und dass jemand da war, speichern wir dann mal zentral in irgendeiner Datenbank, so haben wir nicht gewettet, meine Jungs
So und Mädels, also so läuft's nicht.
Ich bin wie gesagt, also ich ich hätt's jetzt wieder ein bisschen anders verstanden, aber dieser Bericht der BBC ist irgendwie auch unklar. Letztendlich wird äh werden die das irgendwie im Zweifelsfall klären und ähm dann,
wartet.
Wir dürfen also weiterhin gespannt sein, wann es den anonymen dezentralen Check-In geben wird und müssen auch, müssen uns aber da, dass er ja auch nochmal,
der wird das auf jeden Fall das Problem haben, dass jemand einen QR-Code machen kann und andere den abfotografieren können, das ist eine Eigenschaft von QR-Codes,
und ähm das wird da ebenso möglich sein, dass Menschen sich spezifisch mit ihrem Telefon,
einchecken in ein, was weiß ich, Millionen Event, was es was so nie stattgefunden hat. Das wird möglich sein. Das müssen diese Menschen aber manuell für sich und ihr Gerät machen,
Und wie gesagt, bei der zentralen Datenhaltung der Luca App ist es so, dass ich den Tim einchecken kann.
Und der dann alarmiert wird.
Vom Gesundheitsamt und in Quarantäne geschickt. Ja.
Hier geswattet. Ne, und das, das ist ein Unterschied und die,
das sind äh eben also ne der gleiche Vorgang, ich scanne einen QR-Code äh sieht für die Nutzerin vollständig gleich aus,
hat aber eben im im Hintergrund komplett andere Konsequenzen und technische Manifestationen.
Ich kann das Thema nicht mehr hören. Jetzt kommen wir zu Artikel dreizehn.
Auch so ein schönes Thema, über das wir eigentlich längst nicht mehr sprechen wollten. Da hat jetzt also eine äh Bundestagsanhörung zu stattgefunden. Julia Reder, die ja bei uns ähm,
zu Gast ist, ähm hat da äh vorgetragen, sie ist jetzt bei der.
Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte war früher ähm was war sie denn da? Schattenbericht erst. Wie nennt man das denn? Wie nennt man denn ihr.
Berichterstatterin.
Berichterstatterin, ja? Weil der, aber der eigentliche Berichterstatter war doch der Axel Voss.
Ach so, äh Entschuldigung, ja das da hast du natürlich Recht. Ähm.
Schattenberichterstatter.
Dass ja kann sein. Ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt grad nicht.
Ähm auf jeden Fall die, die kompetente äh Ansprechpartnerin. Das können wir, glaube ich, einfach mal festhalten.
Ja die einzige, die das verstanden hat.
Wir kennen auch ihre Argumentation, dass es eben auch intelligente Uploadfilter eben nicht zuverlässig zwischen Parodie, Zitat, Pastisch und Raubkopie erlaubte und verbotener Nutzung unterscheiden können.
Und sie hat ein schönes ähm Beispiel dafür genannt,
übrigens auch ein schönes Beispiel, weil wir werden ja immer wieder gefragt, warum veröffentlicht ihr nicht auf diese,
Auf dieser Startup-Webseite, die versucht an Google zu verkaufen. Ähm weil dann da die Upload-Filter sind und diesen schönen Song von,
Danger, denn den ihr bei uns in voller Qualität in wunderschöner Bandbreite hören konntet und den hat äh Christian Solmecke einen Anwalt, der auf YouTube äh sich sehr viel ähm sehr viel Zeit verbringt mit dem Senden auf YouTube.
Der wollte über diesen Song sprechen und ist dann an den Upload-Filtern gescheitert, weil äh dieser Song eben im Verleih bei Warner ist oder was und Vana hat halt die äh Upload-Filter daran,
Es äh ist dann eben also
wirklich natürlich ein sehr schönes Beispiel für eben die Unzulänglichkeit von Uploadfiltern, weil hier ja ein juristischer Experte, ein,
Zeitgeschichtlichen Fall der Kultur und der politischen Debatte behandeln möchte und zu diesem Zwecke.
Eben Ausschnitte aus dem Musikvideo zeigt, um diese einer Bewertung zu unterziehen. Und das ist natürlich ein absolut legitimes Anliegen, was der Christian Säumecke da verfolgt hat äh und ist aber leider äh am laufende Band daran,
gescheitert und muss konnte dann sein Video nur veröffentlichen ohne auch nur Kleinstausschnitte aus dem Danger Dane Video mit drin zu haben.
Aber sieht halt leider danach aus, dass äh dass dieser Uploadfilter eben, also dieser Artikel dreizehn kommt eben durch und das war ja auch leider zu erwarten.
Ja, war absehbar, ja.
So, dann gab es eine, wir haben das, ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir's. Also wir haben's nicht in Ruhe behandelt, ja? Ähm es gab die ähm.
Es gab das Debakel um das besondere elektronische Anwaltspostfach.
Eben so eine Art D-Mail für Juristen, ne? Und also ein System, was als sicher definiert ist, aber ähm.
Sagen wir mal, dass eher eine juristische Definition ist als eine technische Tatsache. Situation. Und dagegen haben,
Anwälte geklagt.
Die gesagt haben, Moment mal, wir haben ja hier äh bestimmte Anforderungen an den Geheimnisschutz, ja und wir möchten einen,
unseren Anspruch, ne? Also für den Schutz unserer Kommunikation, ne, haben wir besondere rechtliche Anforderungen, besondere Privilegien und deswegen möchten wir den Anspruch,
geltend machen, dass wir das sicherste technische System,
haben. Also ein Ende zu Ende verschlüsseltes. Und sie haben quasi argumentiert, dass die Bundesrechtsanwaltskammer, die ja die Betreiberin des BA ist, hier kein Ermessensspielraum hat, zu definieren, was sicher ist und was nicht,
und der und dass sie deswegen,
nicht haben wollen, ne? Sie haben gesagt, das ist nicht nach Stand der Technik, nicht nach höchstem Sicherheit und deswegen wollen wir das nicht haben. Aber BGH hat
und dass der Bundesgerichtshof eben höchstrichterliches Urteil geurteilt, dass die Bundesrechtsanwaltskammer ein Ermessen hat, hier ein hinreichend sicheres und nicht das sicherste System
zu bauen.
Der BGH hat jetzt geurteilt, dass das BEA hinreichend sicher ist und damit auch sicher im Rechtssinne.
Das ist ein bedauerliches Urteil, ne? Weil es wäre natürlich schön gewesen, wenn man hier,
ja aus den Demonstrationen der äh der Schwachstellen gelernt hätte.
Ähm aber ja, haben eben jetzt wieder Juristen äh geschaut. Es gäbe noch eine
Also die letzte Möglichkeit, die die Anwältin und Anwälte jetzt noch haben, wäre die Verfassungsbeschwerde, weil das ist ja jetzt ein BGH-Urteil, aber
ob sie die einreichen können oder nicht und ob das aussichtsreich ist oder nicht, äh hängt eben auch von der Urteilsbegründung ab und die ist bisher noch nicht da,
Ähm gibt jetzt nur eben, ne, die Entscheidung in der Sache. Ja, äh.
Wir wehren uns höchst richterlich mit Händen und Füßen gegen die Vernunft. Und äh so geht's, so geht's rund.
Ist natürlich juristisch auch wahrscheinlich ein schwieriges Terrain, ich kann das natürlich nicht wirklich ähm beurteilen, aber
solche Sachen wie das sicherst Mögliche und so weiter, ist natürlich dann wirklich echt eine Definitionsfrage, wo man sich fragen muss, okay, wer definiert denn sicherst möglich? Kommt da nicht morgen gleich jemand um die Ecke und sagt, hier das ist aber jetzt noch sicher
noch sicherer
Ich glaub das ist so ein bisschen die Logik die hinter dieser Formulierung hinreichend sicher steht. Die kann ich auch nachvollziehen, allerdings kann ich die Einschätzung, dass das System hinreichend sicher ist so nicht unbedingt nachvollziehen wir
und da bräuchte es wahrscheinlich auch einfach mal ja eine eine Instanz, die,
mal definieren könnte, was hinreichend sicher ist in Deutschland, sodass sich auch alle an sowas orientieren können. Also die quasi so einen Standard setzen, ne? Also, dass man sagt
für unsere Bundeskommunikation
Das und das ist jetzt mal so der Mindeststandard, der einzuhalten ist. Auch wenn er natürlich am Ende oder zumindest im ersten Schritt auch nichts anderes bei rauskommen würde, als äh machen wir das doch so wie beim BA.
Ich ich erinnere mich an, ich glaube das war die Anhörung zum Gesetz. Ähm.
Wo es um die Zulassung der D-Mail im äh Verkehr mit den Gerichten ging, viele Jahre her, aber da hat ein dort anwesender Jurist mich auch quasi zurechtgewiesen, hat gesagt, sie können eine,
Klage auf einer Postkarte einreichen. Und hat damit, ne, das ist, äh, hat damit quasi argumentiert, dass ähm.
Und das das erinnert mich hier daran, ne? Wie gesagt, hier lesen wieder zwei Nerds ähm,
Code, den sie nicht ganz verstehen, aber die Argumentation hat im Prinzip gesagt für den digitalen Bereich muss jetzt keine höhere,
Sicherheit gelten als,
in anderen Bereichen vorgesehen ist. Ja, er hatte gesagt, das können sie per Fax machen, das ist auch eine unverschlüsselte Übertragung. Es zwingt sie niemand, die Klageschrift in Umschlag zu parken. Sie können das auch auf einer Postkarte machen oder auf dem Bierdeckel, ne
und,
Das war, das war die Argumentation, die er da vorgetragen hat. Und ich habe die natürlich aus einer, aus einer gesellschaftlichen und technischen Perspektive überhaupt nicht vertreten, weil ich eben auch sage, nee, weißt du mit
mit diesen Datensammlungen zentral und so nur mit digital ist das Risiko halt größer, ne? Ähm aber es erscheint mir,
so, dass dass das hier die Argumentation ist mit hinreichend sicher und Erhöhung von ne, also Abweichung vom aktuellen Status quo. Also ich halte die für gesellschaftlich falsch, aber ich kann sie äh juristisch.
Konnte ich das nachvollziehen, was der Mann oder kann ich inzwischen nachvollziehen, was der Mann mir äh sagen wollte.
Ja und was wollen sie denn eigentlich, so sicherer als Fax.
Ja, so besser ist es Fortschritt hier.
Es ist noch geiler als Postkarte.
Wir haben ja viel oder wir reden ja hier viel über zentrale Datensammlungen, zentrale Datensammlungen, haben die Eigenschaft, dass
äh zentral, viele Daten auf einem Haufen sind und wenn Zahl zentral viele Daten auf einem Haufen sind, dann sind sie eben auch zentral abgreifbar. Eine Eigenschaft, die dezentrale Systeme nicht unbedingt haben. Facebook ist ein zentrales System.
Tim, ich wollte ja schon immer mal eine SMS schreiben.
Du hast meine Nummer nicht, ne?
Erzähl doch mal.
Ja, sieht so aus, als ob ähm Facebook mal wieder ein paar Daten abhanden gekommen sind. Das ist jetzt in dem Sinne nichts Neues, äh Listen mit Profilauszügen von Facebook,
wo unter anderem eben auch Handynummern drin waren
wurde schon zwanzig achtzehn äh in der Größenordnung von dreißig Millionen ähm was auf dem Netz durch die Gegend geschoben
zwanzig neunzehn gab's dann gleich nochmal fünf vierhundertneunzehn Millionen Facebook Accounts, die veröffentlicht wurden, auch damit Telefonnummern und jetzt vor einer Woche,
gab's dann nochmal ein Update, weil gibt ja auch genug Accounts so und äh jetzt geht ein Datensatz rum mit fünfhundertdreiunddreißig Millionen,
einträgen und auch hier wieder mit Telefonnummern. Ich habe das auch sofort bemerkt,
Weil ich auf einmal so viele Pakete angekündigt bekommen habe.
Oh nein, echt.
Ja. Also die waren immer schon gerade auf dem Weg und gleich geht's los und so und so ein so ein Link,
der dann immerhin nicht in irgend so einem HTMA-Gewand daher kam, das heißt, man konnte der URL auch sofort ansehen, was das für ein Schmuck ist. Aber es ist ja dann eben so darauf setzen ja solche Attacken auch,
Wenn du in dem Moment einfach ohnehin ein Paket erwartest. Na, die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist nicht ganz gering.
Dann denkst du über sowas nicht groß nach und du hast irgendwie so einen Link schneller geklickt als äh drüber nachgedacht hast
Ich habe Gott sei Dank vorher nachgedacht und auch sofort die Nummern äh gesperrt. Das war in letzter Zeit ohnehin öfter nötig, auch weil ich irgendwie die ganze Zeit Anrufe aus Indien bekommen habe, die mir irgendwie beim Beheben meiner Windows zehn Probleme helfen wollten.
Aber du hast.
Try.
Nee, aber du hast einen guten, du hast einen guten Punkt. Wenn du irgendwo jemanden anrufst, ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass die Person gerade minus zehn Probleme hat, nicht besonders gering, ne? Und.
Oder dass dass sie eher einreden kannst, dass sie eins hat, so, ja.
Und wenn, wenn drei, vier Leute sagen hm ist dir das ja egal ne? Wenn du bei den anderen sieben sagen ja scheiße gut, dass sie anrufen ich sitze hier gerade mit der Kacke ähm ne das also.
Ich bin da, ich bin der Immun, also äh mir kann in der Hinsicht nichts passieren. Ich habe übrigens gestern bei äh durch Zufall nachgerechnet, wann ich das letzte Mal ernsthaft,
Das ist jetzt kein Witz, ja? Äh das letzte Mal ein Produkt von Microsoft produktiv benutzt habe.
Also sozusagen, wo ich, wo ich die eine App ein Stück Programm von Microsoft so verwendet habe, um damit Dinge zu tun.
Du wirst dich wundern, aber ich sage dir gleich, dass du falsch liegst, aber sag mal, ja.
Dass ich falsch liege, womit.
Ich korrigiere dich gleich, aber sag mal wann das war.
Du meinst, weil ich jetzt irgendwie einmal gezwungen war in dieser Panimie irgendwo in Teams aufzumachen oder so, also,
Okay, gut, sorry, für Mist. Ja, wat, was kaufen die? Was überredest du mich auch immer wieder, das zu benutzen? Du bist schuld.
Weißt du, was ich was ich mir echt schön vorstelle, Tim, wenn diese Windows zehn Inder bei dir anrufen und du nicht eher Ruhe gibst, als dass die Mac US installiert haben und ihre Buchhaltung mit Money Money machen.
Ich kriege euch alle. Ja, ja, das ist ein bisschen Gegenattack.
So, jetzt machen wir mal, jetzt machen wir Umsatzsteuervoranmeldung. So, das ist ganz einfach. Die Surf-Please, einito Calls haben wir die Als.
No no no no, no, you can't's go.
Förderst die Hälfte Typin De Numbers.
Ähm.
Ja, aber da mache ich dann den Drosten und habe, habe äh Besseres zu tun.
Okay, aber äh genau, jetzt äh.
Letzte Produkt, wo auch Microsoft drauf stand. Nee, ich habe wirklich irgendwie äh mal nachgedacht und das ist tatsächlich fünfunddreißig Jahre her.
Bist du noch nicht gechipt oder was? Auch nicht.
Ne? Kommt vielleicht noch. Ja oder habe ich irgendwie Microsof.
Fünfunddreißig Jahre, welches Produkt war das.
Drei null. Also nicht für Windows, sondern für Doss. Das war geil. Danach ging's bergab mit Microsoft.
Ich glaube, die die Gummiversion war wird sechs erst, oder?
Das weiß ich nicht, das hieß dann alles wie für Vinos und für was weiß ich ja egal.
Äh für Workrooms. Hm, also ich nutze Teams, Word, PowerPoint, Excel.
Auf jeden Fall Facebook hat eine Menge Daten,
und die streuen sie jetzt übers Netz. Haben sie natürlich nicht selber gemacht, sondern wurde ihnen irgendwie entwendet. Das ist ja das Problem. Das könnte teuer werden. Netzpolitik, Org.
Ich glaube Andre war das, ne? Andre Meister,
hat sich dann gleich mal dieses Datensatzes angenommen, also geguckt, welche Bundestagsabgeordneten denn da so zu finden sind, äh irgendwie gleich mal so siebzig Handynummern von denen gefunden, die auch mal fleißig angerufen und so gefragt, was die denn da so von halten, waren natürlich alle ganz
entsetzt, ne? So, haben wohl auch schon ein paar neue Telefonnummern,
Das ist halt so ein bisschen das Problem mit äh solchen Sachen. Also ich bin gespannt, was da,
Jetzt passieren wird, weil das ist ja eigentlich eine klare klare Verstoß gegen die DSGVO und das könnte teuer werden.
Ähm Andre hat übrigens auch getwittert, das war so ein Replay, äh dass sie haben ja nur irgendwie nach nach Bundestag gegrappt. Ja, sie haben jetzt nicht,
nochmal sich die Lustliste der Bundestagsabgeordneten und ihrer Mitarbeiterin und so weiter gesucht und spezifisch nach dem Namen gesucht und so sind sie nur über Bundestags oder die
äh die als als Arbeitsplatzbundestag oder sowas angegeben hat. So so war die Suche. Das heißt äh wahrscheinlich hätten sie mit mehr Mühe auch ähm.
Noch mehr Bundestagsabgeordnete gefunden und,
Was sie ja auch schreiben in dem Artikel ist, sie haben die Leute angerufen, gesagt, übrigens hier, ne, ich habe ich habe ihre Nummer aus dem Facebook Datenleck und ähm,
Damit haben die zu, also das war deren Notification, weil Facebook, denen das nicht gesagt hatte, ne? Und das kann natürlich erst recht teuer werden,
für äh für Facebook, wenn irgendwie Andre Meister den Leuten das eher mitteilt als ähm als sie.
Ja also hundertprozentig kann ich's natürlich jetzt nicht sagen, aber es ist sehr wahrscheinlich, dass dieses Lied jetzt auch tatsächlich für meinen erhöhten äh SMS-Erhalt in den letzten Tagen,
verantwortlich war, weil das lag jetzt zeitlich mal so nah zur zusammen und es gibt auch viele andere Berichte, dass das jetzt so der bevorzugte äh Scam war, weil das halt irgendwie am besten funktioniert. Alle kriegen gerade Pakete. Da kannst du eigentlich äh,
Kannst du da fast wahrscheinlich jedem was schreiben. Jeder wartet gerade auf irgendeine Lieferung von irgendwas, ne. So ist es halt.
Schreibt Andre auch, ne? Sie haben fast alle mit denen sie da telefoniert haben, hatten in letzter Zeit schon Fake SMS mit Links auf Schadsoftware erhalten. Geil.
Sehr schön. Ja, das BSI warnt auch vor dieser Smishingwelle und äh läuft also, läuft.
So dann äh Cap Captain Obwies hat äh herausgefunden äh Deutschlands öffentliche Hand versagt bei der Digitalisierung.
Ja
Dass äh da hat aber einer mal richtig recherchiert.
Ja, also sie haben vor allem festgestellt, es liegt nicht an den Mitteln, sondern am Koordinations und Organisationsversagen. Ja, äh.
Archarische Zustände.
Ja, schön ist der Bundeswirtschaftsminister Peter Altmaier, begrüßte die Empfehlungen. Der Beirat weist zurecht darauf hin, dass Finanzmittel allein noch kein Allheim sind. Genauso braucht es mehr Bereitschaft zu Veränderungen und verbesserte organisatorische
Abläufe. Unbürokratische und dezentrale Lösungen.
Die der Beirat etwa für die Arbeit im Homeoffice befürwortet, können uns hierbei weiterbringen. Danke Peter Altmaier.
Dann wissen wir, wie es jetzt weitergeht.
Das ich meine, das ist so ein wiederkehrendes Thema und ich glaube, da haben wir auch schon ein paar Mal äh drüber gesäuft, ne, aber,
Ich frage mich ja auch immer wieder, was ist eigentlich der Grund? Also wenn man's vielleicht auch mal von der,
öffentlichen Verwaltung bisschen entkoppelt, da kommt sicherlich nochmal dieser Zusatzfaktor haben wir schon immer so gemacht, bürokratische Abläufe, alles in Stein gemeißelt, so läuft das hier seit hundert Jahren und keiner ist bereit, sich zu ändern. Okay,
das sehe ich, ne? Das, das kann sein. Das ist aber wahrscheinlich in jeder Bürokratie so,
gibt's irgendetwas kulturelles, spezifisches, was bei uns irgendwo noch äh mit drin hängt, was uns da nochmal besonders resistent gegen den Wandel macht, das ist immer das, was mich nicht loslässt, diese Frage.
Weiß nicht Tim, ich kann dir das nicht sagen, ich weiß nur das haben wir schon immer so gemacht.
Es ist.
Ähm es gibt ja irgendwie so etwas.
Also ich behandle das auch manchmal in Vorträgen. Es gibt ja so.
Etwas, was sich Deutsche Gründlichkeit nennt und dass Deutschland nicht ähm dafür bekannt ist, Speerspitze der Innovation zu sein,
aber ähm die Innovation dann eben.
Nachhaltig und gründlich umzusetzen. Na ähm.
Ja aber das ist ja mittlerweile ein Mythos, oder?
Genau, so der, so der Mythos, so der Mythos, ähm aber wenn der, wenn, wenn der so ist, dann ist der in etwas wie ähm Mechanik.
Ja? Ähm umsetzbar, ne? Du kannst Dinge
stabiler bauen, du kannst an den Stahlregierungen besser forschen, ne? Du kannst irgendwie einen Motor machen, der noch mit höherer Präzision gefertigt ist und äh sowas, ne, das geht. Das ist da, da ist Gründlichkeit, Langsamkeit, Innovationsfeind,
keit in gewisser Weise kann da ähm zu was besserem,
führen, insbesondere wenn du eine Affinität zur Komplexität hast,
und sagst so Komplexität sind wir gewachsen, wir bauen komplizierte Dinge
kann uns keiner nachbauen, die patentieren wir und solche Scherze, ne? Das ist ja, also das ist ja in der in der Mechanik, in der Welt der Mechanik durchaus relevant.
Ähm wenn du aber dann in der digitalen Welt bist, wo du siehst, je komplexer, das wird, desto mehr,
geht fliegt uns das um die Ohren und wo der Komplexität irgendwo keine natürlichen Grenzen mehr gesetzt sind, wie in der Mechanik
dann denkst du halt, du machst das jetzt hier mit deutscher Gründlichkeit, machst du dir untern verschlüsseln wir hier nochmal und dann machen wir einen einen Q,
Code auf den Schlüsselanhänger und und hier machen wir einen Datenbankpasswort und dann machen wir zentral, aber das alles machen wir ein hohes Risiko, aber das machen wir ja alles sicher, ne? Und dann baust du dir halt so ein
so ein Schrott dahin und ich würde wirklich sagen, dass dieses Paradigma äh zu sagen ähm.
Wir wir machen das gründlich und weil wir es gründlich machen, können wir uns höhere Risiken erlauben, dass,
dass eben diese fehlgeleitete diese fehlgeleitete Deutschtümelei ist, die dich jetzt die die uns jetzt eben überholt.
Also grad dieses Argument mit dem mit dem gründlich, dass das glaube ich irgendwie,
Also das verfängt bei mir nicht diese Argumentation, weil eigentlich, wenn man mal drüber nachdenkt, gründlich heißt ja.
Man analysiert das Problem wirklich von allen Seiten, macht mal so eine Beschlussfassung und dann setzt man das irgendwie um und das kann auch digital funktionieren. Da sind jetzt die Prozesse nicht so sehr viel anders als bei der Komplexität einer großen Textilmaschine oder anderen äh
Werten, die der die der deutsche Maschinenbau in den letzten paarhundert Jahren regelmäßig immer wieder nach vorne gebracht hat. Es ist
ist irgendetwas spezifisches in diesem digitalen was.
Oder zu zu viel abreißt auf einmal mit dem wir uns irgendwie nicht beschäftigen,
wollen und irgendwo auch so eine gewisse Visionslosigkeit.
Ich glaube es es ich glaube es ist weißt du wenn du Dinge gründlich machst dann kannst du dich irgendwann darauf ausruhen. Und das das mit dem Ausruhen macht der Deutsche auch sehr gern.
Deutsche.
Ja, ich wei.
Und und dieses, ne, wir man macht die Dinge, um also und und das fällt ja so ein bisschen weg.
Ich weiß nicht, also mir ist es irgendwie noch um alles ein bisschen zu zu steriotypisch. Stell bloß einfach fest, wenn ich jetzt mal so dreißig Jahre zurückschaue, was wir alles so für digitale Wellen gesehen haben. Es gab ja auch immer
gute Ansätze. So, es gab durchaus gute Ziele, die dann ähm teilweise nicht oder nicht zumindest nicht konsequent
weiterverfolgt wurden. Wir waren auch schon mal ganz weit vorne. Die Digitalisierung des Telefonnetzes, Anfang der neunziger Jahre mit dem ganzen ISTN System. Das war mit Abstand das Beste, was es weltweit gab,
Aber so richtig.
Also das das war ja wirklich richtig viel besser als vorher. Es ist schon spezifisch diese Internetkultur, wo Deutschland dann irgendwie aus der Spur gegangen ist.
Es ist schon diese Dominanz von Software und vielleicht auch so ein bisschen dieses Entwickeln von unten, dieses äh dynamisch sein, dieses dieses agile Werkeln und dieses ab
kommen von von alten Entwicklungsstrukturen, was.
Irgendwie dann noch sich gepaart hat mit so einer so einer so einer so einer Skepsis. Und vielleicht ist es auch einfach so, dass das dieser Innovationszyklus zu schnell ist,
unsere Gesellschaft da mitkommt, dass wir einfach,
vorher immer genug Zeit hatten, dann diesen Wandel auch zur Kenntnis zu nehmen und den dann irgendwie auch auf unsere Art und Weise auszuführen, aber dass wir mit diesen Turnarauen Zeiten, die dieser digitale Wandel zwangsläufig mit sich bringt
auf einmal gesellschaftlich nicht mehr mithalten können mit unserer veralteten Gesellschaft, die einfach viel zu viele alte Leute hat, die einfach
tödliche Probleme haben, diesen ganzen Wandel auch mitzumachen. So und,
irgendwann klar merkt's hier dann auch jeder, nur dann sind ja andere Gesellschaften schon wieder äh entwischt,
Egal, wir müssen das offenlassen und da könnt ihr auch gerne mal zu dokumentieren und wenn da passende Theorien äh habt oder kennt, die das irgendwie erklärlich macht.
Ich halte meine Erklärung schon für halbwegs wegweisend, aber ich bin mir sicher, dass äh Leute, die in in äh in Innovationsfeindlichen Bereichen arbeiten.
Oder gearbeitet haben, noch bessere äh Erklärungen haben.
Ja, keine Erklärung hat man manchmal und da sind wir wieder bei äh Facebook.
Was was dann so diese ganze Innovationsbegeisterung macht, wenn wenn die Algorithmen komplett äh frei drehen. Facebook hat ja jetzt schon äh längere Zeit äh das Problem, dass sie irgendwie versuchen müssen, das Anstößige aus dem Netz zu entfernen,
Ja, also nicht Nazis oder Schwobler oder so, sondern äh Busen und so und böse Worte, die Leute sagen, ja,
so ein bisschen geht da dieser amerikanische äh Piepkultur irgendwie, glaube ich, mit denen auch ein bisschen durch. Das ist auch so etwas, was ich, was ich nicht so richtig verstehe und wo ich, wo ich die Amerikaner nie so richtig auf die Kette kriege, aber dieses ganze,
People von Fuck und was was man da äh alles angeblich nicht sagen darf, weil ja was eigentlich, was passiert denn dann.
Ja? Also was befürchten die denn eigentlich, wenn jemand fuck sagt? Dass das Leute zum Waffen greifen und ganze Schulen niederschießt.
Nee, dass dann, dass das äh dass Menschen mit der Tatsache konfrontiert werden, dass es Fucking gibt. Aber gibt's ja nicht mehr. Fucking ist ja weg.
Gibt's nicht mehr. Fucking hat sich unbedingt ein ein fucking.
Hat sich umgetan. Unglaublich, die Katze.
Die wussten schon vorher, was passiert.
Nee, ich glaube die, ich glaube, die haben, die haben sich ja umbenannt, weil diese nicht sich nicht mehr leisten konnten, ihr ihr Ortseingangsschild zu bewachen, ne.
Du hast die ganze Zeit geklaut wurde.
Wird den jeden Abend abmontiert.
Genau, eine andere Gefahr, die bestanden hätte, aber die sie jetzt gar nicht voll auskosten können, ist, dass sie einfach von Facebook komplett einfach mit ihrer Gemeindewebseite gesperrt werden,
die wohlgemeinden heutzutage schon so haben. Das musste aber jetzt das kleine äh Städtchen ähm in Frankreich erfahren mit dem zauberhaften Namen Bitch.
Will, die Beach.
So, kannst du doch, du kannst doch eine Dorf, wenn du das äh liebevoll aussprichst, kannst du doch auch durchaus äh bitch äh sagen.
Bitte schreibt sich das.
Ja, das das man muss ja jetzt, man darf das einfach nicht so hart immer nehmen.
Genau.
Wird es liebevolle, bitte.
Also der Algorithmus hat zugeschlagen, hat beschlossen, dass irgendwie diese Seite von äh dem Beach einfach mal überhaupt nicht ging,
Voging, bitte. Die fucking Bitche wurde dann automatisch entfernt,
Um's gleich vorweg zu nehmen, hat nicht lange gehalten, also natürlich haben sich alle total drüber aufgeregt und sogar Facebook musste dann einsehen, dass die Algorithmus dann mal ein bisschen über die Strecke geschlagen,
das offenes Gerät von Frankreich, wo die sowieso an Glophob sind. Das ist wirklich echt unglaublich. Aber man sieht auch gleich, welche Auswirkungen das hat, weil das Nachbarstädtchen heißt nämlich Rohrbach äh,
Ja, man gleich mal das Libitch rausgenommen, ne, um dich auch gespirtzt werden.
Ja.
Ja, so kann man auf sich aufmerksam machen. Von diesem Ort wusste bis eben noch überhaupt keiner was und jetzt wollen alle mal Urlaub machen und sich irgendwie neben diesem Schild äh fotografieren lassen, solange bis es dann der Gemeinde auf den Senkel geht und sie sich umbenennen müssen, denn äh
was eigentlich irgendwas. Wir können uns ja auch mal umbinden. Wir nennen's einfach ein Lok Bitch Look Bitch. Log Beach und Netzpolitik.
Wir haben doch äh tatsächlich sogar äh das war ja sogar die äh die die Erklärung, dass wir auf dieser übrigens von einem Franzosen betriebenen äh Blogliste stehen, die einige in ihre Respury.
Ah, daher kommt das äh das.
Weil wir Lok im Namen haben.
Ach, wegen Lok.
Das war also der hat halt auch also.
Nee, Quatsch, der pflegt die ja nicht, der hat ja einfach nur einmal, was weiß ich. Also jetzt kannst du auch vergessen.
Du alte Beach? Bitche!
Beach, Alter. Wir wir blocken eure wir blocken euch ein Dorf nach dem ander.
Genau mit unserem Freund Zuckerberg.
Lockpitch, Netzpolitik hier wieder loggen kann, wie wir wollen.
Ja, Lock, Beachdiller, Politikdüre so. Und das müsst ihr irgendwie wieder instatiiert werden. Oh Mann. Haben wir was Lustiges zum Ende gehabt? Ist doch auch schön.
Nockbitch.
Ja, also so so ist das.
Genau. Apropos Lock Beach äh,
Ich war ein bisschen fleißig und habe äh mit meinen beiden Traditionswagen gehuldigt und habe äh alte Sendungen mal ordentlich durchtranskrebiert, so die automatischen Systeme da noch was brauchbares rausgeschmissen haben,
und habe bis auf weniger äh Ausnahmen, wo einfach mal partout keine,
Multitrickaufnahme so ohne weiteres vorlag oder zu erzeugen war die letzten fünf Jahre Logbuch quasi durch suchbar,
gemacht, noch nicht in dem Maße durchsuchbar, dass wir hier schon einen User Interface zum Durchsuchen aller Sendungen hätten,
Ich hoffe, das wird's irgendwann mal äh geben. An der Stelle vielleicht kurzer Verweis auf das wunderschöne Podcastverzeichnis Füt F, Y D,
Punkt DE, dass der Christian macht und der hat da auch schon ein experimentelles Transkriptionsdurchsuch-Feature drin, weil diese Transkripte ja auch den Suchmaschinen bereitgestellt werden, so sie sind,
nutzen möchten und da kann man dann tatsächlich äh Podcastübergreifend,
suchen, also man kann's glaube ich noch nicht auf einen Podcast beschränken, aber zumindest kann man über alle Podcasts, über alle Episoden suchen
Na ja und ihr könnt zumindest auch diese Transkripte äh verwenden zum recherchieren und ich hoffe, dass wir dann auch irgendwann mal so ein richtiges schönes Recherchetool äh haben, wo man dann sagen kann, so in welcher Sendung hat Linus äh Bitch gesagt.
Dann nicht nur in einer. Ich möchte übrigens, heute ist die Sendung Tim, die hier live,
in der Sendung kommt ein Tweet nach dem anderen, erst pult Andreas den äh den Private Key aus dem äh Gitlap von von der Luca App. Jetzt twittert Anne Roth,
vielleicht doch keine fünf Blockchains. Und die badische Zeitung bestätigt das, es ist es sieht so aus,
also hier Zitat,
entgegen der entgegen den ursprünglich diskutierten Konzepten soll bei der Lösung nicht auf die verschlüsselnstechnik von sogenannten Blockchains gesetzt werden, sondern auf traditionelle Verschlüsselungstechn.
Das ist Deutschland. Wir sitzen dann wieder auf traditionelle Verschlüsselungstechnik. Wie wird es schon immer gemacht haben? Na toll, wo bleibt die Innovation? Ich will meine Blockchains haben.
Ja, scheiße, ich wollte einen Blockchain im Pass. Jetzt, ja, ich kriege ja eh keinen im Pass, aber jetzt machen wir äh jetzt machen wir eine Kiasmus-Impf im im Fass.
Traditionelle traditionelle deutsche Handverschlüsselung. Da wird jedes Bit noch einzeln geflipp.
Was ist denn traditionelle Falsch.
Nicht, weil ich, da gibt's bestimmt irgendein Bundesamt für Bundesamt für Verschlüsselung, gibt's bestimmt wohl auch noch, die Schalter umgelegt werden.
Er soll noch vor den Sommerferien kommen. Da bin ich übrigens auch interessiert, ne? Wenn die jetzt schon die Leute geimpft haben, ne.
Und man schon im Darknet da irgendwie seine äh Aufkleberchen für die für Impfbüchlein kriegt und so, ne,
wie die dann am Ende ähm valide digitale Unfeldspare, Blockchain-Impfpässe aus dem Papier machen. Aber das, das werden die sich sicherlich bei Gelegenheit auch noch Gedanken drüber machen. Notfalls hat's Mudo da besten Lösungen.
Mit deutscher Gründlichkeit wird das Problem bestimmt ordentlich zerredet werden, bis keiner mehr bereit ist, irgendwas zu entscheiden.
Ist alle geimpft sind.
Wirklich. Oh Mann, hoffentlich gibt's bald eine Impfung gegen Vollidiotie, das wäre wirklich mal dringend erforderlich. Egal, Leute, das war's für heute,
Damit müsst ihr jetzt erstmal leben. Ich hoffe, ihr hattet trotzdem Spaß.
Ja tschüss. Ja. Tschau, tschau.